قتل اربعه اسرائيليين من اصل سبعه في هجوم
شنه مقاوما فلسطينيان في مستوطنه علي
الواقع في الضفه الغربيه وسرعت قوات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لتعقب المنفذين
وتصفيتهما فيما تدعت قيادات سياسيه وامنيه
اسرائيليه الى موقع العمليه والصدعوات
داخل حكومه نتنياهو للرد بشن عمليه عسكريه
واسعه في الضفه الغربيه وغيرها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما اهم الدلالات
والرسائل التي تضمنتها العمليه التي
نفذتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه في مستوطنه
علي وسط الضفه وما خيارات حكومه نتنياهو
في التعامل مع تصاعدي عمليات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه كم من وكيفا ردا على
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه وما المسارات
الميدانيه والسياسيه المحتمله فضل منطقه
خاصه ما تعلق منها بجهود التهدئه التي
نشطت مؤخرا برعايه اقليميه ودوليه
[موسيقى]
لم تمهل المقاومه الفلسطينيه جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي طويلا ساعات بعد عمليه جنين
يوم الاثنين التي خلفت اصابات في الجنود
واعطاب اليات عسكريه ها هي مستوطنات عيله
تشهد هجوما اسفر عن مقتل اربعه من اصل
سبعه اسرائيليين تعرضوا له العمليه تردد
صداها بقوه وعلى اعلى المستويات حتى قبل
ان يستكمل الجيش الاسرائيلي تصفيه
المهاجمين رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو قال انما حدث في عيله
عملية اجراميه مفزعه وسنواصل العمل ضد
الارهاب وكل الخيارات مفتوحه الترجمه
العمليه لذلك قد تكون مصرح به وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي اعتماد بن جزير حاله
وصوله لموقع العمليه قائلا ان الوقت حان
لعمليه عسكريه واسعه النطاق في الضفه
الغربيه كما حان الوقت لتنفيذ عمليات
اغتيال وتمرير قانون اعدام من وصفهم
بالمخربين
قالت حركه حماس التي اكدت انتماء احد
المهاجمين لجناحها العسكري ان عمليه عيل
رساله واضحه لحكومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وهي رد على مخططات تقسيم الاقصى قريبا من
ذلك قالت حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه ان عمليه
مستوطنه عالي الفدائيه هي رد طبيعي على
جرائم الاحتلال المتصاعده بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القدس سامي
خائن مراسل الشؤون الدبلوماسيه في هيئه
البث الاسرائيليه سيد ميخائي لاي حد شكلت
العمليه مفاجاه خاصه بالنسبه للتقارب
الزمني للعمليه التي تبنتها حماس اليوم
المنفذين ينتميان لحركه حماس وبين عمليه
البارحه في جنين التي اسفرت عن اصابات
كبيره في جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واعطاب
اليات ومدرعات
طبعا
الهجمات الارهابيه على المواطنين
الاسرائيليين للاسف ليست مفاجاه للاسف
نتوقعها ان تحدث كل يوم هي ليست لها علاقه
باي عمليه في الضفه الغربيه لان ما رايناه
في الاسابيع والاشهر القليله الماضيه هو
المزيد من الهجمات
الارهابيه
باستخدام السلاح ليس
بالسكاكين او هي باستخدام بنادق من نوع
كلاشنكوف اي كي 47
وغيرها والتي زادت في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه في الضفه الغربيه وهذا الهجوم
للاسف انتهى بموت اربعه مدنيين
اسرائيليين لهذا السبب
نسمع كل هذه الاصوات في اسرائيل التي
تطالب بشن العمليات العسكريه في الضفه
الغربيه ضد خلايا
الارهابيين لانهم يظهرون الممتلكون من
السلاح والذخائر اكثر مما تصور
الاسرائيليه ولكن سؤالي كان قصدي به
مفاجاه من حيث نوعيه السلاح المستخدم من
حيث القدرات وتطور القدرات بين البارحه
واليوم قدرات المقاومه الفلسطينيه وايضا
عنصر المباغه والمفاجاه حتى بان هناك
اعتراف من الجانب الاسرائيلي بغياب
المعلومات
الاستخباريه عن امكانيه تنفيذ حتى مثل هذه
العمليه اذا هناك خلل
طبعا انا اعترف بان من الصعوبه بمكان
لاجهزه الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه ان تعرف
مكان ونوايا كل ارهابي فلسطيني
سيصحو ذات صباح يحمل سلاحه ويذهب لمهاجمه
هدف اسرائيلي هذا امر صعب للغايه
وليس من السهل ان نتوقع مكانه ووقت حدوث
كل عمليه لكن للاسف
المفاجاه التي لا اعدها مفاجاه لاننا لا
نعيش اوقاتا هادئه مستقره في اسرائيل وفي
الضفه الغربيه راينا الكثير من الهجمات
الارهابيه على شاكلته هجومي هذا اليوم
ومحاولاتها الهجمات ايضا للاسف لا نعيش
اوقات هادئه في اسرائيل الان
للاسف
لنقل
المسرح يغلي بكل هذه العمليات ومحاولات
عمليات من قبل الخلايا الارهابيه وسنرى
المزيد منها في الاشهر والاسابيع المقبله
الان هناك جلسه مشاورات بين نتنياهو
كبار القاده الامنيين تبحث خطه سابقه لشن
عمليه عسكريه محدوده في ظل احاديث عن
مطالب من قبل
الاعضاء الحكومه الاسرائيليه الارشاد
تطرفا ويمينيه مثل
يتحدثون عن اهميه الذهاب لعمليه واسعه
النطاق وتنفيذ اغتيالات ايضا وتفعيل قانون
اعدام المنفذين ما هي الخيارات المتاحه
امام حكومات نتنياهو
دعونا نتحدث اولا عن الجانب السياسي الذي
تحدثت عنه مثل
طالباني بعمليات اقوى في الضفه الغربيه
هذه هي الدعوات ليست وريده اليوم هي عمرها
اشهر واسابيع وما حدث ان الدفاع جالات
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو قال لهؤلاء
دعونا اولا ننتظر لنرى لكننا نصل نقطه
ربما ترى فيها المؤسسه العسكريه والمؤسسه
الاستخباريه
انهم يحتاج البلد يحتاج الى تسريعي وتيره
الردود
وشدتها على هذه الاهداف هذه لا ادري انا
تحديدا لكن اعتقد ان هذه القضيه المطروحه
على الطاوله
دعونا نقول بكل صراحه ووضوح لو ان هذه
العمليه لم تتم ربما بعض الثمن الذي دفعه
الاسرائيليون كان سيكون اعلى لا احد
يتساءل حول هذا العمليات رايناه في
السنوات والاشهر
والاسابيع الماضيه ما كانت لي تتم لكن اذا
لم تتم هذه العمليات كان عدد اكبر من
الاسرائيليين سينتهي به الامر الى ان يقتل
لهذا السبب
الاسرائيليون مؤخرا في السنوات القليله
الماضيه جربوا تخطيطا جديدا في الماضي كنا
نرى عمليات كبيره عمليات اغلاق
الفلسطيني مراسل الشؤون الدبلوماسيه في
هيئه الب ث الاسرائيليه
تعميق النقاش ينضم الينا من الخليل عادل
شديد الباحث المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه
ومن رام الله الدكتور علي الجرباوي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت مرحبا
بكما الدكتور جرباوي ما اهم الدلالات
والرسائل التي ارادت المقاومه ارسالها من
خلال عمليه اليوم التي اتت بعد عمليه
البارحه التي يعني فاجات ايضا القوات
المقتحمه في جنين قوات الاحتلال
يعني ممكن افكر في اربع اشياء اولا ان كل
فعل له رد فعل هذا هذا اول اول استخلاص
يعني تريد المقاومه الفلسطينيه ان تفهمه
لاسرائيل وللحكومه الاسرائيليه
ثانيا ان الرد
الذي سياتي غير معروف اين سياتي ولكنه
سياتي يعني فلذلك يعني عنصر المفاجاه
الفلسطينيه اصبح متوفر وثالثا ان الرد
الذي سياتي هو قوي وفعال وليس يعني رد
قليل الفاعليه
اسرائيليون يقتلون
مركبات عسكريه تعطب وجنود
يجرحون ويعني كل ذلك
والامر الرابع هو ان الرساله الاهم بجوز
هي ان لم يعد امر الحسم الذي تريده هذه
الحكومه اليمينيه المتطرفه
لوضع الضفه الغربيه لم يعد سهلا على
اسرائيل بل اصبح تقريبا متعسر ومتعسر جدا
لم يعد بامكان اسرائيل ان تتصرف في الضفه
الغربيه بدون هذا بدون ردود فعل وبدون ان
يكون في حسابها ان الضفه الغربيه مفتوحه
تتصرف فيها كما تشاء
سيد شديد عدد شديد انت معنا من الخليل
بطبيعه الحال الحكومه الاسرائيليه الان
تبحث طبيعه الرد ونوعيته وهل سيكون موسع
ام سيكون محدود ما هي الخيارات من وجهه
نظرك
تحياتي لك والدكتور علي الجرباوي
ولكافه المتابعين والمشاهدين لا شك انه
عمليه اليوم النوعيه
عمقت ازمه الحكومه الاسرائيليه الازمه
اللي بمجموعه اتجاهات ليست ازمه امنيه
عسكريه انما
ازمه سياسيه وخاصه انه
نتنياهو المؤمن بالقوه العسكريه الى انه
يعمل باتجاه ما يسمى بالحل الاقتصادي اي
عمليه عسكريه واسعه ستؤثر سلبا على مشروع
ما يسمى بالحل الاقتصادي والتصاريح
والتسعينات وفتح الطرقات في الوقت الذي
يطالب فيه قاتل المستوطنين
منع الفلسطينيين من استخدام شوارع
الجفافيه التي يستخدمها المستوطنين
والكثير من الاجراءات التي ستفشل مشروع
الحاله الاقتصادي ولكن عمليه اليوم اللي
بالوقت اللي
التي تخضع للاحتلال الدائم والسيطره
الامنيه الاسرائيليه وما من يوم الا
ويتعرض هؤلاء
لهجمات المستوطنين حرك مع حصولاتهم تحطيم
منازلهم
شهداء ان تاتي هذه العمليه اعتقد انه كل
هذا يشكل انه يعطي العمليه اهميه
بالغه
جمل مختصره عن خيارات برايك سيذهب الى مثل
عمليه موسعه ام محدوده
يعني بتقديري لا يمكن نتنياه ان يذهب
باتجاه عمليه واسعه بسبب بسيط انه
الاحتلال موجود بالضفه الغربيه عامل 2002
كانت الضفه او مدن الضفه وجزء من بلداتها
يخضع للسيطره الامنيه الفلسطينيه كانت
هنالك سلطه كان في ادعاء انه غياب الجيش
الاسرائيلي واتفاقيه هي التي ادت الى نضوج
وانتاج بنيه تحتيه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
اليوم الاحتلال يحتل كل سنتيمتر بالضفه
الغربيه بالتالي الذهاب باتجاه عمليه
عسكريه كما تحدثنا سيؤدي الى تاجيل الغضب
والاحتقان وانتاج عمليات مقاومه جديده ثم
ثم كما تحدثنا في البدايه انه كل توصيات
الاجهزه الامنيه انه اي عمليه عسكريه
واسعه قد لا تاتي بالنتائج المرجوه بل
بنتائج عكسيه تماما من شانها زياده العمل
[موسيقى]
الجرباوي ايضا الى اين ستذهب المنطقه
ميدانيا وسياسيا على ضوء هذا التصعيد
الجاري المناسق الاممي لعمليه السلام
بالشرق الاوسط
تفاعل مع التطورات الجاريه في الضفه
الغربيه قائلا احث كل الاطراف على
الامتناع عن خطوات قد تزيد وضع متفجر
الدكتور علي الجرباوي
هل تنظر الى
ان المشهد هو حتما ذاهب باتجاه تصعيد مع
محاولات
اقليميه ربما او ايضا مدعومه دوليا من قبل
واشنطن من اجل التهدئه وعدم الذهاب
للتصعيد
يعني التهدئه ممكن ان
يتم محاوله لتحقيقها ولكن يجب ان يكون
هناك اطراف معروفه لتحقيقها معها الان
القضيه الاساسيه بالنسبه لاسرائيل ان
الطرف المقاوم هو طرف غير معروف ولا يمكن
التوصل لتفاهمات معه وليس السلطه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه وليس حركه حماس في
قطاع غزه هو افراد فلسطينيين شبان ليس لهم
راس وليس لهم هيكليه لذلك لا من من سيتحدث
مع من يعني لذلك ما في امكانيه على
الاطلاق للتواصل الى تفاهمات الان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه امام ضغط ضغط اولا من قبل
يعني جهتين الجهه الاولى تعطيها راي بين
قوسين مهني هي الجيش والشباك يعني جهاز
الاستخبارات
وهم ضد هذه العمليه لانه غير مع اهدافها
غير معروف ماذا ستحقق وهناك تخوفات من حجم
السلبيات التي ستنجم عنها بالمقابل هناك
اطراف يمينيه تتحكم بهذه الحكومه هذه
الحكومه في اسرائيل الان هي حكومه دوله
المستوطنين هي حكومه ما يسمى بدوله يهودا
والسامره وليس حكومه اسرائيل في تل ابيب
لذلك هناك ضغط من المستوطنين
على هذه الحكومه من اجل القيام بعمليه هذه
العمليه قد لا تكون بالحجم الذي كانت فيه
في عام 2002 ولكن هناك ضغط شديد على
نتنياهو وهو الذي سيقرر في النهايه مصلحته
في ابقاء الائتلاف اذا ما تعرض هذا
الائتلاف لخطر التفكك ام انه سيبقى على
راي الجيش بان عمليه متدحرجه هي يعني
جاريه منذ اشهر هذه العمليه كل يوم هناك
اقتحامات وانقل ما قلته الدكتور علي لسيد
عادل شديد يعني
بالاضافه الى ما تحدث عنه الدكتور علي هل
ترى بان
الحاله الدوليه
الدافعه باتجاه التهدئه ستنجح في جعل
نتنياهو يذهب الى عمليه عسكريه محدوده ام
ماذا
يعني لا اعتقد ان هنالك ضغط دولي او نشاط
دولي باتجاه التهدئه صحيح انه هنالك حاجه
اقليميه
والكثير من الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه
لها مصلحه ولكن اليوم اعتقد انه التركيبه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه تحول دون ذلك
ذهاب للحكومه التي
تضمير يتناقض تماما مع فلسفه مع جوهرها مع
برنامجها وهذا يضيف مازق جديد
لليمين الديني بالموضوع وبالتالي مستبعه
ثم الحاله الفلسطينيه الداخليه كما تحدث
الدكتور علي انه نحن الان امام مقاومه وما
يميز المقاومه الحاليه ليس انه لا يوجد
لها عنوان
بقدر ما انه يوجد لها حاضنه شعبيه واسعه
جدا بتقديري ستلفظ اي توجه من هذا القبيل
اعتقد ان اليوم احد الاسباب المهمه جدا
لتصاعد الاعمال المقاومه الحاليه مسالتين
الاولى نجاح تلك العمليات واللي بيشكل
تعزيز الثقه بالذات وما يسمى بالنقاش
الاسرائيلي بمحاوله تقليد العمليه ناجحه
ثم ان هنالك انطباعا ورايا فلسطينيا عاما
يرى ان اسرائيل لا تفهم الا ما شاهدته
اليوم في عيله وبالامس في جنين هذا
الانطباع اعتقد انه اليوم هو اللي بيشكل
المنتج
الحاله الرافعه للثقافه والبيئه الكفاحيه
التي تنتج
هذا العمليات بعد الانطباع بعد عن تراجع
تاييد الفلسطيني للمفاوضات وللعمليه
السياسيه بعد فشلها وليس فقط الفشل بعد ان
اقتنعت الاغلبيه الفلسطينيه انه عمليه
اوسلو
اتت بخراب اكثر بكثير من الاعمال
والنتائج الايجابيه او الانجازات التي
وعدت الفلسطينيه بالتالي نحن اليوم امام
بيئه بيئه منتجه لهذه المقاومه واعتقد انه
احنا في دربتها وستستمر من الخليل العدل
شديد الباحث والمختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
ومن رام الله الدكتور علي الجرباوي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت شكرا
لكما
لهنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]